I'm Young on The Super Family's third movie.
I have a few announcements to make before you watch this video.
Ten members have joined The Super Family between the last video and this video.
They are Korok-Va, Le-Vok-Va, Nu-Vok-Va, and Galak-Va.
Others are Baby-Tess, her father is Bethias, and her mother is Clermflower.
Then we have Basil-State here.
Then it's Gex and Gexarica.
Mind Gex's language, please.
Hello, Stacie.
Your voice has changed.
Aren't you supposed to be making breakfast?
My voice has changed because...
Oh, you upset throat.
No.
I got my com-tools to clean up.
Hmm.
I don't know what the reason for that is this week.
Hey, you guys have changed into a hunk of kaita.
Yeah!
Don't we look cool?
Yes, you do.
Where's the babies?
Did they wake up yet?
They're still in the crate.
Stacie, we're just going to go next door to, um, like, pick up the kids because remember they were babysat.
Oh, yeah.
But who was it again?
By whom?
Yeah.
Sheila, wasn't it?
No.
Sheila doesn't live next door.
She lives here.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, wait a minute.
Our neighbors live, like, millions of miles away.
Down in the legs.
Yeah.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Can I help you?
Um, I'm going to go put the peas away.
Well, that was not very hard.
Yeah.
Hey, Cornflower.
Cornflower.
What?
Can you, um, take care of baby, um, Timmy over here because he really wants to play?
Sure.
Yeah, I want to play.
I'll go get her.
Um, Stacie went off to school.
I guess you can help me make breakfast.
Hi.
Again.
It's been two years.
Yes?
It's terrible.
You're only supposed to call on this hotline if you're calmed down.
I thought I told you that before.
No.
You lost your mind because you don't know how to do it.
Oh, you're a different person.
Sorry.
How is that possible?
Is it serious?
You should just go about your work.
Yeah.
I'm busy.
Eh.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Sure.
Yeah, we'll be there in about, like, let's say 20 minutes.
Yeah.
Yeah, we can walk there.
Is it urgent?
Very urgent.
Not really.
It's Makuta.
Makuta.
He is.
He has done it again.
He rose.
But he's lost.
From the dead.
But this is the last time we have to destroy him, because if we hit him with the full force
of the Super Family, then we can destroy him for sure, because we aren't taking off as Chrono
this time.
Someone's at the door.
I'll be back.
Oh, what's your name?
What's your name again?
Butch.
Oh.
We've got 20 minutes until Makuta.
Until we've got to go destroy Makuta.
We're going to play video games.
Bam!
Kids these days.
Before we go.
Go.
What is it, Stacey?
A piece of cheese.
Cheese.
You know, always trying to get out.
Something's right at the door and I can't get the milk out of the freezer.
Especially that white thing.
I mean that black and white thing.
Yeah, he looks like a skunk.
Do you think we should let him out?
Nah.
He's going to cause too much mayhem.
I don't want to be cleaning up before we leave to go fight.
Maybe we won't.
Okay.
Yes.
Let's let him out.
And thank you, Little Sunstrike.
Come on.
Is he always going to the desk?
Go on.
Alright, now we can...
Hey, you guys.
Oh, no.
We can't do it.
Didn't Butch tell you?
No.
Hey, little guy.
You guys want to play football?
No.
Oh, gosh.
Geez.
We're not going to kill you.
Spoilsport.
That guy out here.
Yes?
I thought you called me earlier about this.
Probably Kristen.
Kristen, I have...
Oh.
Sorry, moms.
Yeah?
Yeah.
That one.
We're going to be leaving this room to destroy you-know-who.
Yeah.
Stacy, tell her that she's got to come quick.
You've got to come quick because we've got to battle you-know-who.
I know.
It's so weird.
Who cares?
Yeah?
We're going to destroy them.
Okay.
Now you won't even come in five minutes.
You can't.
Thanks, Mom.
You want me to come in five minutes?
I'm going to come in here in five minutes now.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, wait a second.
You're not my friend.
Soon I will rule the Earth.
Yeah.
Now it's time to put my good body to work.
Better than last time.
I even have three masks.
Yeah.
Last time we lost a mask and then we lost.
This is it.
Now I have to put them away.
You know that you guys look like a huge Tohunga.
Yeah, we do.
We never noticed that.
Did you know if you have six Tohungas, you're a Tohunga?
Yeah.
You can like create a huge robot.
Oh, we didn't know that.
All right.
I got to do my stretches.
Look what I found.
Loogie eggs.
Practice my sword skills because we're going to have to go.
Put the loogie eggs in a little nest.
Hopefully, they'll hatch by the time we get back.
Hopefully.
Now you get back in your cage.
You had enough, Papa.
Nice skills, huh?
Tohunga, think you can take it this time?
Yeah, but I'm not sure.
I don't think so.
Maybe Ta-Hu did some special moves.
Who knows?
Maybe Makuta has some new tricks up his sleeve.
Another loogie egg.
Destroy droid egg.
Yeah, it's a destroy droid sack.
They call them sacks.
There's necks and just normal.
You want a training room?
Sure.
Okay.
This will be a great spot for the loogie eggs.
Yes.
It's so cool.
I'm sure it is hot in here, but it's higher gravity in here, so that's how we can fly.
The higher gravity you train at, the more you're able to jump.
Yep, and the more I can do backfads.
If you could jump really high on super high gravity, then you're going to jump super,
super high on Earth.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
My lucky number one basement.
This is Baby Sunstrike.
Big power.
What was that?
I can do that.
Big power.
Makuta will be scared of that.
Because you're the scariest monster I ever saw.
Big power.
Oop.
For Jam Jam.
A worm such as this will be able to make an attack that big.
Guess what, little guy?
Big power.
The dog.
The doggy.
This is bad.
Hello?
Time someone told me about that.
We are going to be there.
You said you need to come.
We need to come now.
Okay, that's it.
Okay.
Everyone, let's get ready to go.
We must go now.
There's his lair.
We'll be there soon, quickly.
Avoid the basket, everybody.
I can see it down there.
Here we go.
Prepare for landing.
There's my lair.
Makuta.
It's good we avoided the basket.
I'll sit right down on this rock.
Ugh.
Who's going to battle him first?
Bella, your family will go first, okay?
Badger's first.
Bella?
Let's battle now.
Attack.
She is too soft.
Why are there so many wheels?
Why do you not battle like this?
Why isn't she talking?
Remember me.
Knock her out.
Now.
She's still in battling condition.
She is no longer able to battle.
We have to defeat her.
I have failed.
I will destroy you.
For my kids.
And the other people.
Get him.
Scoop and mask.
Here we go.
How'd you like that, Makuta?
Knock two masks off at the same time.
He is too powerful.
A weakling, I hear.
Back him.
You are a weakling.
Nice saw sharp.
Sudden flash?
Yes.
Me.
Now let me meditate a quick.
Okay.
If you're going to meditate, then I'm going to.
Now I have to meditate.
Um.
Round.
It's because I'm stronger than you.
You sure about that?
Yes.
I am sure.
Huh.
You're pretty stupid anyway.
Basketball net attack.
Watch this.
It affected him.
What can I do to defeat him?
Viper beam.
There's something wrong with him.
Who gets the weak people?
He didn't even hit me.
It went up into a ball in the sky.
It'll stay there until the end.
Well, anyway.
These things don't scare me.
A weak attack.
What a weak attack.
He finished you off.
I knew that that was a weakling.
How about I knock you out?
Huh.
She's getting back up.
We're up there in the sky.
I wonder what it's for.
Oh well.
It's for something special.
Dan the squirrel.
Yes.
Me.
Now.
We're up in the sky.
We.
Will.
Um.
Oh.
What's that word again?
Oh well.
I'll just destroy you.
He always fights like this.
Didn't he do that?
I mean.
What was that?
Oh.
Is it true that you are a father of a family of four?
Why yes.
That is.
Nice trick, Makuta.
But you'll take some of this kick.
Meditation.
No.
I've done it in my last battle.
So.
How can it be unamazing.
Amazing.
Now.
Oh yeah.
You did.
Well.
Watch this.
Mask of Invisitor.
There goes your mask.
I'm still here Makuta.
Song the squirrel.
Attack him.
Attack her.
Final beam thing.
The hard way.
Baby Jess.
Attack her.
Harder than the rest.
I want torture on her.
You mean.
Why didn't she attack her?
She's talking.
Super.
First.
She's taking out.
First she does that final beam thing.
So it's like me's sisters.
You only have one sister.
Let's use the hyper beam on him.
All right.
Quickly.
He's just a baby.
Aita.
Once again.
I'm still going to defeat you the way I did last time.
We have changed.
We have three lives now.
Hyper kick.
Pretty good Makuta.
But now it's my turn.
He has lost a life.
Sh.
I'm putting it back on.
That was pretty good Makuta.
Yeah it is.
What's that?
She is too much soft.
Hyper beam.
Now wait a minute.
Hit her with the super pin missile.
Hit her quick while she's on the ground.
Hard so she's knocked out.
No.
Flank so she can't walk.
Flank so she can't even stand up.
Her with the super hyper beam.
Hyper beam.
Time for you to go down.
Okay.
The Rowdy Ruff Boys?
Couldn't you pronounce that?
It would be hard to take these masks off.
Yes, Moaca, get him.
Let's knock him out.
Powerpuff Girls, get them!
These guys never talk.
Give them something!
Come on, Blossom.
Teresa?
To my dad.
He's not very strong in the head, Makuta.
He's good.
I'm going to take a nap.
Please wake up, Makuta.
I think I have a concussion.
Good job, Moaca.
I've got an extra dinner for you tomorrow.
If we destroy them.
We must destroy the next family.
Giant Mode!
Aku Aku?
Yes, it's us.
And Grandma Pikachu.
Now!
Pikachu, use your Shish Kabob attack.
Shish Kabob?
Dang it, it's only me.
Hit them with your laser vision.
Because I'm about to be knocked out.
Powerful attack before you get knocked out.
Yes, failed.
It's your turn.
Sheila and Agent 9.
Watch out for Agent 9's blaster.
Watch out for my blaster.
Use your super kick.
They look like rhinos.
Yeah, from where we come, they look a lot like them.
What?
That Sheila means girl in Australian.
Let me look in the dictionary and see if that's true.
How do you like that?
If that's the way you want to play, I'm using my tail now.
I failed.
Thais and cornflower.
Yes.
And you will go down.
Just as I defeated Cloony in the...
When I was in Redwall.
And using the same sword too.
Now, let's battle.
Here's my wrench.
I'm gonna have to fight you.
I thought a mouse would be...
You'll see.
Let's battle it.
Attack it.
Don't do that.
It'll only make it harder.
Don't press down on that like that.
Yeah, pick the mask off.
Ouch!
They're buzz saws.
Attack him, quickly!
It's Baby Matimeo and Tess.
That attack was devastating.
I mean, even though they're just kids.
Spirit bomb.
Ha, didn't destroy me much.
Ah, I have to reach that mask.
The kids.
My, my, my, my.
No one.
It's a weakling.
Just look.
What, are you slow?
I cannot fix myself.
Oh, that buzz saw thing's getting boring.
Use something else, like fire, like fire burst.
Why isn't she going to follow her final beam?
Baby Ella?
Too easy.
She'll never defeat me.
You can pause off me, you dang dirty ape.
Exerica?
Wheels.
Punch her, quick!
Fusion!
Use confusion!
It's failed.
We're all sleepy.
We'll both have the love shield.
There's no way nobody can, there's no way anybody can defeat me now.
It's the Toa!
Turaga first.
Let's get ready.
Then we'll destroy you, Makuta.
That's impossible.
That's an ice pick.
Stay aside.
We have our night vision masks on.
Ha.
I want those for my collection.
I'm changing masks.
I'm taking a rest, Makuta.
Strength.
Ah!
Now I put on.
Kick!
At least somebody thinks they won't destroy me, but will help.
That's even dumber than saying that.
What?
Oh, let's just battle.
Matau.
I'm changing masks.
This is bad.
Change masks.
I control you, Conrad.
To release your mask.
And you won't be able to understand me.
So you don't know when I'll attack.
I understand your secret talk, so I'll know when you'll be able to attack next.
I don't believe that.
I battled in my spirit.
That's Lewa!
You guys didn't know.
As Anua said, we did battle.
You just didn't know it because you were dead in the head that day.
And you still are today.
Break, Anua.
Yeah.
I feel kind of tired.
All right, Makuta.
It's just you and me because Anua's taking a break.
It's the easiest weapon, so it's easy to knock off masks with it.
I'm changing masks.
X-ray vision.
Now I can see the tension in your body.
And your muscles where you're going to attack next.
You don't even have any.
Since you're such weaklings.
I'm unbeatable.
Unlike the others, I don't have a sword.
I have an axe.
I'm changing masks.
Please change your mask.
I hate doing it.
And it annoys you.
You mean big, right?
You have to do a stand here and attack you and you won't be able to get me.
Iwaka.
Conrad.
He can't hear us.
Now, attack him from behind.
That mask can only protect against the...
The attacks that he can see.
So attack him from behind.
No, attack him.
Then he'll concentrate on you and not Nui-Rama.
Ha, you can't hit me.
I'm changing masks.
I can get out my gold mask.
I'm getting my...
My mask of vision.
So I can see your next move.
No, get my...
Disappearing mask.
See, I disappeared.
But I can see your claws.
So I can still hit you.
I'm attacking.
If we attack both...
Stretch his hands and knock this mask off.
Good job, Conrad.
I mean, Iwaka.
I'm really gonna use an attack that'll scare you, Makuta.
Makuta.
Why'd you like that, Makuta?
That certainly is the mask of strength.
But watch this.
That you're doing.
There's pay...
You'll pay for your wrong doings.
Right here.
With...
And my axe blade will be the buyer.
The guy who takes my...
He takes the money.
Hey, it's dusty down there.
Makuta.
Something that you don't have.
I've fainted.
And failed.
I've already used my last attack.
It's up to me.
My last attack...
Because I'm about to be knocked...
That attack didn't even hit me.
It's Tahu and Gally.
Yes, it does.
And I'm so Gally.
But you will find out that she's the smartest Toa.
But I'm smart...
Second smartest.
But that's true that I can kill some...
The people in the Super Family?
No, it is not true.
Laywell was just joking around to make you overconfident.
None of us in the Super Family will ever die.
By old age or even...
Or even weakness...
Or...
Or being defeated in a battle.
We will just get knocked out.
Yeah, I will heal again.
Very quickly.
Come on, sis.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
I forgot we had to battle first.
The Eternal Fire!
I want to burn that.
I want to make that burn out.
I have the Mask of Invisibility.
You can't see me.
Hey.
Pretty.
Who is he?
I'm changing masks.
Wait, Conra.
Thank you.
Confusion.
I'm confusing you.
You must battle.
Yeah.
June 7th and 8th.
Now my foot's back on.
Friday, 9th, Saturday.
I'm slimy.
All right.
I can give you a...
We must battle more.
Now I can...
Actually, the guy's name is...
Hey, that's an idea.
You might want to take your name to register anyway.
I can torture him with it.
He can still feel what happens to it.
I didn't know a Chiraga could do this much damage.
Just tore it up.
Great.
Let me move it up.
No.
Well, his name's Don Carlisle.
You don't care?
Hey, you chewed my head off.
Okay.
Your phone number.
Huh?
Get my head back on my body.
Hey, what's in that thing?
Oh, right.
There's no brain in there.
That's probably why it isn't moving.
Jeez.
I'm careful getting out of his mouth because my head's in.
And my mask as well.
Hey, why'd you...
Hey.
I thought you were against me.
Why'd you open your mouth?
I don't know.
I'm not.
So I can battle you longer.
Chew on you more.
Before you are knocked out.
Last attack.
He spit me out there.
Ah, yum.
This tastes good.
Oh, it tastes the w...
You're going to be fired if I get off your mask.
Ma'am?
Your mouth feels weird.
There.
Now it feels better.
It could have broke your jaw.
Give my mask back.
Don't take that.
Just thinking.
Was my illusion.
Kick, Gally.
I'll try it.
It was slow.
I'm not going to eat you.
Hi, Canoe.
Nice.
But I always heard of one secret.
It's something my friends used to tell me.
Always do this.
It's really fun.
One of the greatest toa.
Don't I look good?
Go on.
Good work, Milwaukee and Cotton Rock.
I'll take care of this.
I'll take care of her.
Don't worry.
You did good.
All right, bro.
Ta who I know.
The ta who I know will protect me.
Well, I'm not that...
Hey, who's ta who?
Our ta who.
Oh, yes, I am.
But I am not going to help the super family.
I've kept this secret up until this point, Gally.
We must battle.
You sound like Kamikuda.
You know, your case came with, like, two videos.
Well, it's time to put it in tape two.
Because we gotta...
Do another video or the story won't be complete.